hallo und herzlich willkommen sagen wir
mal wieder nachdem wir gestern schon
hier einen livestream gesendet haben aus
dem kleinen nordöstlichen bundesstaat
der usa aus new hampshire wo in der
vergangenen nacht die zweite vorwahl zu
ende gegangen ist die zweite vorfall mit
der die demokraten versuchen zu
bestimmen wer denn für sie in das rennen
ums weiße haus gehen soll nach wie vor
sitzen wir im riesengroßen studio
unseres partner senders msnbc wo bis in
den frühen morgenstunden reges treiben
herrschte denn das rennen war über eine
ganz lange strecke nicht klar
auszumachen es blieb spannend an meiner
seite
annette brieger sinha producerin bei uns
im studio zdf studio washington
annette wie hast du die wahlnacht
gestern erlebt es war nach wie vor eine
stunde war nacht fand ich es war nicht
ganz so aufregend wie das vielleicht in
europa gewesen war wo ja die ergebnisse
ewig nicht reinkam wo wir lange lange
warten bis sich überhaupt jemand
geäußert was da los war also gestern
kamen die ergebnisse relativ schnell 7
uhr haben die wahllokale geschlossen um
9 hatten wir dann schon ganz gute
hochrechnungen aber dann hat es doch
noch eine weile gedauert bis bei den
beiden top kandidaten die vorne lagen
bei den beiden herren hat ein bisschen
gedauert
richtig aber für mich war eigentlich der
überraschungsmoment gestern das ergebnis
für die emmi klobusch eine frau die wir
hier zwar schon eine weile beobachten
die aber glaube ich dem zuschauer noch
nicht so ganz bekannt ist die zwar zwar
an dritter stelle also noch nicht der
frontrunner aber sie hat erstaunlich gut
abgeschnitten und das war wichtig dass
sie überleben kann für die nächsten
station jetzt und ich glaube auch dass
ihr das sehr helfen wird in den nächsten
wochen und monaten vor der frau von mick
logischer der senatoren aus minnesota
lagen wie schon angesprochen zwei herren
zum einen wie erwartet wie die umfragen
es vorhergesehen vorausgesagt hatten
die sender der selbsterklärte
demokratische soziale
ganz knapp lag er vorn auf dem ersten
platz dicht auf den fersen folgte ihm
piep oder george ein moderater demokrat
aus indianer bislang bürgermeister einer
kleinstadt der anders als sender eher
auf einheit setzt er will das land einen
er will die partei einen
während senders ja schon sehr lautstark
nach einer politischen revolution ruft
und dabei auch ziemlich kompromisslos
vorgeht
annette du sammelst für uns fragen von
den zuschauerinnen und zuschauern den
userinnen und usern
bitte schicken sie uns schickt uns
weiter euro und ihre fragen zu aber ein
paar hast du schon vorliegen richtig ja
die ersten fragen sind schon gekommen
und das werden auch also das ist jetzt
nicht eine konkrete frage sondern eine
ganze reihe von leuten haben sie
erkundigt nachdem bernie sanders du hast
es angesprochen
das ergebnis war sehr knapp kann er sich
den wirklich freuen über den sieg von
gestern abend
gute frage ich würde sagen er kann sich
sehr wohl freuen denn in euro war in der
angesprochenen ersten vorwahl dem
sogenannten korpus vor rund einer woche
lag er ja ebenfalls kopf an kopf mit
bruder george auf dem zweiten platz also
insgesamt scheint sich da ein ein trend
abzuzeichnen und er kann zurückgreifen
auf eine große leidenschaft große
leidenschaft bei seinen vor allen dingen
jungen jugendlichen anhängern
er kann zurückgreifen auf einen grass
roots moment was er ja eigentlich über
jahre ausgebaut hat und es wird jetzt
weiter gehen nach europa und new
hampshire in südlicher gelegene starken
als nächstes ist nevada dran dann kommen
noch kleiner south carolina
wo mehr minderheiten zur wahl gehen
werden weil dort es dort mehr
minderheiten hispanics und und
afroamerikaner in den jeweiligen staaten
gibt und das ist eine starke basis für
bernie sanders also da zeichnet sich ein
trend ab aber ich gebe mal gleich die
frage an dich zurück
siehst du es überhaupt als möglich an
dass ein selbsterklärter sozialistin das
weiße haus zieht also ich bin ja
beobachte die lage in amerika schöne
ganze weile und ich bin überrascht dass
er es überhaupt so weit geschafft hat er
hatte letztes mal vor vier jahren ja
schon großen erfolg hat es nicht ganz
geschafft und jetzt scheint er sogar
noch mehr momentum zu haben also alle
alle experten hier und die die
talkrunden im fernsehen haben eigentlich
ziemlich deutlich gesagt dass der gewinn
von gestern ihm eine große kraft gibt
einen großen push nach vorne
er hat auch die stimmen der schwarzen er
hat auch die stimmen der latinos hinter
sich vielleicht nicht so viel wie der
beiden sie gehabt hat und bei joe biden
kann man ja auch sagen das ist der große
verlierer des abends der ist noch nicht
ganz raus aus dem rennen er wird noch
nach nevada gehen er wird noch nach
south carolina gehen aber eigentlich
geht niemand mehr davon aus dass er das
noch weit schafft aber bei dem ereignis
sein das muss man sagen dass er
sozusagen die gesamte palette der wähler
bedienen kann
der moderate kandidat politisch ganz nah
auf seinen fersen
da ist dann die frage er hat gut
abgeschnitten besser als erwartet aber
die frage ist kann er dieses momentum
tatsächlich halten denn im gegensatz zu
bernie sanders fehlt ihm die
unterstützung bei den schwarzen bei den
afroamerikanern schloss noch mehr fragen
offen genau und zwar im handy sich und
da würde dann auch jetzt noch mal kommen
deswegen wollte ich den globus noch mal
ins spiel bringen die frage kommen wo
wer ist ökologischer und wofür steht sie
hatte denn eine echte chance und ich
finde das ist eine ganz interessante
frage jetzt für uns auch ich glaube wir
beide sind uns einig sie ist die bislang
unterschätzte kandidatin gewesen aber
vielleicht hat sie als eine kandidatin
der
mitte und gerade auch als frau können
wir gleich noch mal separat den aspekt
diskutieren tatsächlich eine chance sie
ist senatorin eher moderate senatorin
aus dem mittleren westen aus minnesota
sie wirbt um die wähler der mitte sie
steht für pragmatismus von ihr bekommt
man ja praktikable lösungen präsentiert
nicht versprechungen die man nicht
halten kann das hat sie in abgrenzung zu
ihren konkurrenten auch in den
vergangenen wochen immer wieder klar
gemacht
und insofern denke ich hat sie da
vielleicht als eine kandidatin die
zwischen dem sehr jungen peter judge der
ja auch eher moderater demokrat ist und
eben dem der linksorientierten bernie
sanders tatsächlich eine chance und auf
die frage hin ob sie schon etwas
geleistet hat ja sie kann sich rühmen
dafür dass sie eine senatorin ist die
außerordentlich viele gesetzesvorlagen
vorgebracht auf den tisch gelegt und
auch durchgebracht hat sie selber
spricht da immer von über 100
gesetzesvorlagen alleine in den
vergangenen jahren wie siehst du das
kann eine frau in den usa präsidentin
werden sind die usa reif für eine frau
im weißen haus so erschreckend und
erstaunlich das klingt im moment habe
ich da meine zweifel
und ich glaube das ist die diskussion
die geführt wird sowohl bei den wählern
als auch bei den politexperten die
genauso wenig das einschätzen können
glaube ich wie wir im moment das ist
eine der großen fragen erstaunlich bei
einem land wie amerika finde ich wieso
hast du da zweifel woher kommen die
zweifel die mangelnde unterstützung für
kandidaten wie elizabeth warren und auch
lange für mich logisch und das ist auch
nur eine interessante ja mal hillary
clinton es gab der mann hillary clinton
ich meine wahl muss von außen die hat
drei millionen stimmen mehr bekommen als
dann der präsident trump aber es gab
doch große diskussionen auch nach dieser
wahl 2016
woran es gelegen hat und die frage war
es eine frau die das auch verhauen hat
wurde auch häufig gestellt
ich würde aber noch einen anderen aspekt
mit reinbringen bodycheck 38 jahre alt
und bürgermeister eines kleinen einer
kleinen stadt im mittleren westen
der hat es ihre weit geschafft der hat
es sehr schnell weit geschafft und da
deuten halt auch immer wieder wähler und
und leute die das intensiv beobachten
darauf hin und sagen wie kann es so ein
junger mann schaffen während eine
erfahrene frau wie die emi klobusch um
jede stimme kämpfen müsst da gibt es
übrigens auch ein paar interessante
fragen zu andy fragt auf facebook können
die demokraten sich hinter einem
provinzpolitiker pete im zweifel
versammeln und marietta das ist im
prinzip eine frage die da sich
anschließt kann senders sich jetzt
sicher sein aufgestellt zu werden also
senders und pete die beiden auf die
läuft es immer wieder hinaus also klar
ist es noch nicht es stehen jetzt noch
eine steht jetzt noch eine reihe von
vorwahlen an wir sehen das jetzt nach
euro war und new hampshire pitt oder
george und bernie sanders tatsächlich
vorne liegen aber ich glaube so ein
bisschen liegt ja in der frage auch wird
er tatsächlich aufgestellt werden
ja die frage danach wird er von seiner
partei den demokraten dem esstisch mit
dem vorstand der demokratischen partei
unterstützt 2016 ist bernie sanders ja
schon mal angetreten
im rennen ums weiße haus und damals hat
das ästhetisch nennt ihn nicht
unterstützt sondern war er an der seite
der in anführungsstrichen gesetzten vom
partei establishment gesetzten
kandidatin hillary clinton und diese
zweifel gibt es jetzt natürlich erneut
die partei
die verantwortlichen in der partei
machen sich sorgen um die so genannte
elektrolyte um die wählbarkeit wir haben
schon kurz angerissen ist amerika reif
für einen sozialisten für einen so links
ausgerichteten kandidaten oder wird er
tatsächlich im rennen ums weiße haus im
herbst dann gegen donald trump verlieren
weil er einfach nicht eine mehrheit im
gesamten amerika mitnimmt und gerade
eben auch eher moderate wähler auch
wechselwähler verschrecken würde ich
würde sogar noch in anderen gedanken
hinzufügen
es gibt wähle die hatten 20 16 16 bernie
sanders sich gewünscht er hat es nicht
geschafft und man würde vermuten dass
jemand der einen so linken kandidaten
wie den bernie sanders wählt großem
abstand hält von den republikanern dabei
im gegenteil sie sind zu trump
rübergegangen der sind die wechselwähler
und da lag es dann vielleicht weniger an
der politik für die die republikaner
oder demokraten stehen die ihr nun weit
genug auseinander liegt sondern es sind
diese protestwähler man kann also auch
davon ausgehen dass der bernie sanders
eine art populist von links ist das hat
eher zugenommen als abgenommen das heißt
wenn bernie sanders tatsächlich jetzt
wirklich sagen wir mal noch erfolg hat
weiterhin stimmen sammeln kann könnte er
vielleicht sogar eine gestimmt von trump
klauen sie haben dieselbe zielgruppe die
wutbürger sie haben erst so erstaunlich
dass erst haben sie teilweise eine die
gleiche zielgruppe
man könnte aber auch überlegen bin bin
ich sein dass es nicht wird und die
berners wie sie sich gerne selber nennen
haben immer sorge dass das es tablets
mit der dämmung raten die sowieso nicht
will weil sie zu lang sind und dass sie
dann vielleicht irgendwie unfug machen
um den brünig centers zu verhindern
ich glaube mal es gibt da so einige
anzeichen dass zumindest die zweifel
sehr groß sind bei den demokraten
und deswegen ist dann die sorge dass er
vielleicht doch zu traum wieder
zurückgehen und da kommt dann die frage
ganz kurz wir haben eine frage ja noch
unterschlagen nämlich die kann ein so
junger eher unerfahrener bürgermeister
aus einer kleinen stadt in indiana kann
der tatsächlich ins weiße haus ziehen
kann er es schaffen
er selber hat versucht daraus profit zu
schlagen aus seiner unverbrauchtheit aus
seinem jung sein und hat sich explizit
präsentiert als ein washington outsider
aber klar ist dass seine kontrahenten
gerade als das rennen rennen etwas
spannender enger in den vergangenen
tagen und wochen wurde die haben
explizit ihm das vorgeworfen joe biden
du hast den schon angesprochenen
ehemaligen vize-präsidenten er hat in
einem in einer negativ werbung in einer
hand in einem anti wahlwerbespot gegen
pitt oder george hatte explizit seine
erfahrung an der seite von präsident
obama herausgestellt und hat sich ja hat
die erfahrung von peak bruder george in
der kleinstadt band indianer geradezu
ins lächerliche lächerliche gezogen aber
du hast noch eine andere frage ja ich
wollte noch eine sache erwähnen weil auf
youtube ich habe jetzt keinen namen aber
ich vermute dass sich mehrere leute
fragen bei b welcher wählerschaft ist
schon beliebt ich möchte gar nicht so
viel heute über trump reden da kann man
stundenlang sich darüber gedanken machen
aber es ist insofern für diese wahl
wichtig weil halt die frage der tramp
wähler auch in gewisser weise sich ein
bisschen über schneidet mit den wählern
für senders und deswegen an die kollegen
wie gefragt haben oder die zu die die
user die gefragt haben
bei welcher wählerschaft ist schon
beliebt eine antwort ist durchaus auch
bei denen die sich auch bei bonn ist
anders umschauen
aber ich würde noch mal zurückkommen auf
eine andere frage youtube michael roßner
roßner entschuldigung was das für beiden
bedeutet und das ist natürlich wir haben
das vorhin schon mal kurz angedeutet das
ist natürlich sozusagen etwas was ich
schon seit längerer zeit
bemerkbar gemacht hat aber was jetzt
fast sicher ist beiden ist fast raus
also wir beide haben joe biden den
ehemaligen vize-präsidenten von
präsident obama im wahlkampf in euro war
und dann auch hier in new hampshire bei
seinen auftritten live und sehr nah
erlebt überhaupt keine frage das ist ein
sehr erfahrener washington insider
senator gewesen über jahrzehnte und
daneben vize-präsident doch sein
auftritt war dann doch sehr behäbig um
es mal vorsichtig zu sagen er hat immer
wieder vom tod und leiden was er
vielfach in seiner familie am eigenen
leib gespürt hat gesprochen er hat immer
wieder auf obama auf die erfahrung mit
obama im weißen haus verwiesen und viele
wähler haben dann gesagt das land uns
nicht er ist so rückwärtsgewandt wo sind
die innovativen frischen ideen für heute
und für und für morgen und ich denke es
ist gefährlich er ist damit aufgetreten
er hat geworben damit dass er der
populärste der wehl beste kandidat im
rennen ums weiße haus sein könnte und
dass er jetzt zweimal hintereinander ein
solches debakel erlebt hat das geht
nicht wenn man sich als wählbar esther
kandidaten präsentiert dann muss man
auch ergebnisse präsentieren und ich
möchte da mal auch im zweifel setzen
dass die schwarzen wähler jetzt in den
südlicher gelegenen staaten auf die
beiden so sehr setzt dass die schwarzen
ihm das mit der wählbarkeit noch
abnehmen einer anderen namen müssen wir
noch erwähnen dass es wichtig und da
gibt es auch eine frage zu mark sanchez
was wird mit elizabeth warren passieren
wird sie ein ticket zusammen mit senders
machen als vize also grundsätzlich finde
ich die ist es natürlich wichtig zu
fragen des senders galt als eine der
großen hoffnungen es gab eine zeit da
hat die super zahlen gehabt die ist
jetzt auch abgestürzt nicht so schlimm
wie beiden sie wird in nevada bei den
latinos sie wird in south carolina bei
den afroamerikanern gute ergebnisse
vorweisen müssen denn was wir noch gar
nicht erwähnt haben das geld new
hampshire ist als staat jetzt nicht so
wahnsinnig wichtig als bundesstaat aber
wer hier als sieger heraus geht hat ein
wind in den segeln und hat dann auch
vielleicht sogenannte momentum der
berühmt berüchtigte richtig das
sogenannte momentum und momentum
bedeutet geld moment bedeutet
aufmerksamkeit und das braucht man in
diesem riesigen land muss man weite
strecken reisen um von bundesstaat zu
bundesstaat zu kommen elisabeth wollen
ist diejenige die jetzt wirklich gucken
muss wie kommt sie denn von new
hampshire nach nevada wert bezahlt das
ticket bezahlt einen riesigen aufbau in
ihrem wahlkampfbüro dort das sind die
entscheidenden fragen für sie ob sie das
weiter schafft oder nicht bernie sanders
ist für viele und so hat er sich auch
immer wieder präsentiert der pure der
reine kandidat des progressiven
demokraten flügels seit jahren um mich
zu sagen seit jahrzehnten steht er
tatsächlich zu denselben zielen kampf
der wallstreet kampf den milliardären im
land er setzt sich konsequent für
gesundheitsversicherung für alle ein
elizabeth warren hat da in den letzten
wochen ein paar abstriche gemacht hat
gesagt krankenversicherung für alle ja
aber mit einer gewissen schonfrist würde
sie würde sie präsidentin dass das
einführen sie versucht sich jetzt nicht
als ganz radikal links progressiv zu
zeigen sondern als eine die auch brücken
bauen kann hin zum moderat even lager
und es scheint so als hätten die wähler
das original gewählt das original des
linken flügels und eben nicht diejenigen
die jetzt die linken progressiven ideen
ein bisschen aufgeweicht hat und zur
frage ob sie wohl die richtige geeignete
vize kandidatin
vize-präsidentschaftskandidatin an der
seite von bernie sanders wär ich würde
da mal ein fragezeichen setzen wollen
wäre ich bernie sanders würde ich mich
etwas breiter aufstellen und würde mir
eher eine moderate kandidaten an die
seite holen
ich glaube sie sind halt auch bei den
eltern dass wir haben ja auch noch nicht
über das alter gespart auf was du sagst
es gibt ja es gibt ja auch ein grund
warum bodykit so beliebtes ist es auch
der generationenwechsel
der ist wichtig denn für den steht des
senders natürlich auch nicht
sondern wenn es tatsächlich der kandidat
werden sollte und ich bin mir noch nicht
sicher dass das tatsächlich so kommt das
rennen ist noch weit offen auch wenn
sein dass jetzt wirklich das momentum
hat aber dann sucht er sich sicherlich
einen jüngeren kandidaten oder eine
jüngere kandidaten an seiner seite das
risiko bei senders ist natürlich auch
wird der andere teil der demokraten der
partei diejenigen die jetzt für andere
kandidaten für moderate kandidaten als
bernie sanders sind werden sie wenn er
den kandidat werben sollte im rennen ums
weiße haus werden sie einen senders
unterstützen
aus vollem herzen oder werden da viele
der senders anhänger zu hause der der
moderaten anhänger zu hause bleiben und
eben nicht zu 100 prozent hinter ihm
stehen das wird ein großes risiko für
die partei und würde donald trump in die
hände spielen absolut und das ist das
was wir jetzt alle mit argusaugen
beobachten
wir müssen gleich schluss machen aber da
habe ich doch noch mal eine frage die
gestellt wurde von dieter und die finde
ich ganz wichtig und die können wir auch
nicht wirklich ganz beantworten aber du
kannst man versuchen obwohl dem mal
kommen nämlich schwierig frage es ist
eine sehr offene frage welche
wählergruppe wird die wahl entscheiden
frauen latinos oder ganz andere
was meinst du was schätzt du ich glaube
die frauen sind sehr wichtig wir haben
in ersten erhebungen in der vergangenen
nacht gesehen dass emig logischer ihren
mit ihren sieht aber ihren so lieben
dritten platz gestern unter anderem den
frauen in den suburbs den wechsel
wählerinnen in den vorstädten hier in
new hampshire zu verdanken hat
allerdings muss man aufpassen es gibt
auch viele frauen
die auch nach dreieinhalb jahren
präsidentschaft an der seite von donald
trump stehen also es ist nicht so dass
die frauen automatisch bei den
demokraten zu suchen sind
und ich denke ein 1 1 ein demokratischer
präsident schafft es nicht ohne wie es
hier immer etwas platt und lapidar heißt
ohne die braun und die schwarzen stimmen
also ohne die stimmen der latinos ohne
die stimmen der schwarz gerade bei den
schwarzen das nur als fun fact schwarze
frauen sind die treuesten wähler der
demokraten die es überhaupt gibt ich
glaube es sind irgendwie so um die 80
paaren 80 prozent der schwarzen frauen
die an die wahlurne gehen wählen
tatsächlich einen demokratischen
kandidaten also da werden wir sicherlich
noch eine ganze reihe von von events
sehen auf denen die kandidaten jetzt
auftauchen und um stimmen bei den
schwarzen frauen werden gerade in south
carolina gerade in nevada schaffen wir
noch eine frage erhöht und so einfach ja
ganz interessant vielleicht wäre es
anders bereit zu sein die frage was dann
natürlich bewegen und das kann man
schnell beantworten ich gucke aber noch
einmal es gibt noch ganz viele andere
fragen vielleicht dann doch er noch
einmal ganz kurz claudia bernie sanders
so wie wir ihn jetzt seit vier jahren
hier auf der landesweiten bühne muss man
ja sagen erleben kannst du dir senders
vorstellen als vize dass er sich einer
einer präsidentschaftskandidaten einem
anderen präsidentschaftskandidaten
unterordnet nein nein da ist eine menge
ego mit dabei und ich bin mir auch nicht
sicher dass jemand anderes den sender
mit sich aufs ticket nehmen würde
der weiß ganz genau was er will
revolution und die findet gegebenenfalls
auch im eigenen lager statt und deswegen
würde man sich da doch einen ziemlichen
floh ins bild setzen glaube ich er ist
ein ganz starker kandidat von seiner
meinung das macht ihn stark aber als
vize ist das halt nicht so richtig gut
ich guck mal hier ist noch paul kann zog
hat gefragt gibt es eine erklärung dafür
dass beiden im vergleich zu den umfragen
jetzt zwei mal so schlecht abgeschnitten
hat ich glaube du hast seitlich darauf
geantwortet und hast ja zu behäbig zu
rückwärtsgewandt
das thema alter hat tatsächlich auch
eine rolle gespielt allerdings muss man
sagen
anders als bei bernie sanders der mit 78
ja nun sogar noch älter ist als joe
biden aber man muss ganz klar sehen er
tritt sehr viel lebhafter agiler lauter
auf als joe biden und das interessante
ist ja dass bernie sanders ganz nach wie
vor ganz doll zieht bei den jungen
wählern gar nicht so sehr bei den alten
die verbinden den sozialismus oder beim
begriff sozialismus nach wie vor eher
mit 40er 50er jahre mit der udssr mit
sowjetunion während junge menschen den
begriff sozialismus hier in amerika dann
doch eher verbinden mit einer gewissen
staatlichen fürsorge wie sie zum
beispiel in einigen skandinavischen
staaten seit langem usus ist und dann
die frage als letztes vielleicht noch
von sonja facebook war dass er könnte
bietet das land vereinen ganz wichtige
frage welcher kandidat kann das land
vereinen und gibt es überhaupt einen
kandidaten oder eine kandidatin die das
tun kann
die frage stellt sich bei politisch die
frage stellt sich bei emi klobusch ich
finde der microbus da muss man wirklich
jetzt intensiv beobachten denn sie hat
eine politische position die sehr in der
mitte liegt und bei petric darf man auch
nicht vergessen er ist ein schwuler
kandidat dass er überhaupt so weit
gekommen jetzt finde ich erstaunlich und
ob das letztendlich in einem eher
konservativen südstaat wie south
carolina sei mal dahin gestellt wir
beobachten das aber geht kandidat der
die verschiedenen lager vereinen kann
das wird die große frage sein die partei
die demokratische partei ist in sich
zerrissen das zeigen alleine die beiden
kandidaten die auch hier in new
hampshire genauso wie in europa vorne
lagen
die budget von moderaten lager und
bonnie cent
das von ganz weit vom linken politischen
spektrum die partei müsste geeint werden
aber wir haben immer wieder darüber
berichtet das land die usa sind
zerrissen wie nie und diese
zerrissenheit diese spaltung wird vom
jetzigen präsidenten donald trump nach
wie vor weiter befeuert egal wer bei den
demokraten für die demokraten antritt
der muss ein ganz starker sein um
tatsächlich diese diese brücken schlagen
zu können
annette annette brieger vielen dank für
viele kluge muntere antworten am sehr
frühen morgen nach einer sehr kurzen
nacht ihnen und euch zu hause ganz
herzlichen dank für ihr und euer
interesse
wir sagen tschüss aus dem hampshire